and
um so just to open the
um public agenda for the 28th of
February uh I only have one apology at
the stage which is granting City it's
going to be a little bit late
uh with somebody like to uh
authorize those Trish thank you Barry
um any further Declarations of Interest
being none the public forum is yours so
nickel and Welcome to our meeting you'll
find that we're very informal
good that you bought a team
and Darren will explain those comments
later on
you're a tunakota tunakota Couture
just so I'm just going to do a bit of
high level Something head over to South
but great to be here to have a
conversation about climate resilient
projects here today and I guess after
what we've seen in the north island and
Hawkes Bay in particular in the last
couple of weeks it does bring it into
high focus
and you know what we're doing now is
sort of the short term
will we know there's high risk but
eventually we're going to have to have a
long-term catchment-wide strategy for
for all our um our catchments uh
congratulations for the work that you've
done on the um on stead street that we
know we're going to have to work
together
for the future and a lot of the stuff is
if the funding will be intergenerational
I probably won't say too much more than
that but
um self-landers are pretty good at
working together
as we've seen in the North Island our
turn will come again and we have to be
ready but I'll hand over to Paul to lead
you into that I actually I better
introduce the rest of the team with what
uh Paul Holst
ERS
from staff as well but it was yours Kara
thank you thank you for uh
allowing us to come and present my name
is Paul Wilson the general manager for
integrating catchment management I think
I've been in uh at es for two years now
time flies like when I first got here I
got the challenge of picking up the
climate resilience program it's quite a
it's quite a big program across the
region but I note that it's probably
I've never been here to present so
that's two years so it's quite timely to
come today and give you an update on the
specific infrastructure projects that
we're doing in invercargill so thank you
for that
um do I do I press the buttons or
I want it scroll do I okay really this
slide just in terms of context you are
well aware this was a government uh
funded uh infrastructure program across
the country you were one part of of that
and again uh to the chairs comments all
credit to to get your steadstreet pro
project blood wall and completed we've
still got some projects that we're still
doing as part of that wider program
if we go to the next slide if that's
okay
um so the invercargill City Bank uh stop
grade you can you can read that for
yourself but really we're focusing on
the true left hand side of the white
hole pie and the work underway is to
sort of protect further stabilize the
stock Bank we're looking to widen the
base the and slightly increase the level
uh so in the future that if we wanted to
increase the height of the stock Banks
again in the future that we would have
that that wide base to do it it will
also give us a one in 100 Year level of
service protection which is uh good in
the context of you know the climate
change
um challenges that we're facing and and
also I think you might have picked up in
the Press we we talk a lot about the
interdecard or Pacific oscillation
phenomenon which really means that for
the next 20 years we're going to be in a
negative phase of that of that weather
phenomenon means we're likely to have
longer lasting floods at a higher level
perhaps like you experienced in the late
70s and 80s and so we're expecting that
we're going to get some more uh events
that are going to test the
infrastructure
is and probably worth touching on the
true right hand side and the right hand
side we're not we've prioritized the
work to protect uh the city and the CBD
and we also have a one in 100 Year level
of service for the right hand side so
that allows us
to develop uh through our sort of Master
Plan approach our data that we'll we'll
develop over the next few few months and
in years determine what extra work we
can do in the whole catchment uh and so
that work
provided government funding is available
law there are long-term plan
conversations that that work could also
take place
and but what we're hoping to achieve
through the invercargill stock Bank
upgrade is obviously
increasingly uh in protection on the
left-hand side which is really important
I go to the next slide really that's
just a slide just to show you the type
of work that we're doing uh the type of
fill and rock Protection work that will
happen
I won't dwell too much on that but if
you go to the next slide
um the stead Street stead Street Pump
Station this is a huge project you will
have seen it no doubt at the side of
State Street right next to your your
they work in Tandem and there's a
there's a uh there's a gap in the flood
wall that you've kind of left for us
that we can put our pipes through and we
will close that hole up when that pipe's
gone through but really this this
infrastructure is marked improvement on
what we've had since the I think the
1950s when they originally built to
protect predominantly Farmland now we're
predicting other important assets as
well as Farmland through that thing
through that pump station it's an 11
million dollar project and it's partly
funded by canola and and environment
Southland and will give us
I think I'm probably going to ask you to
go to the next slides because I think
you can see some of the uh some of the
groundwork the one of the the riskiest
points of the of the program was to get
out of the ground as you'll probably
know yourselves it's not the um
it's it's difficult ground conditions
there and so it was a real risk to to be
in a position where we're at the ground
and looking to do the built work but I
can safely say that that's happening now
and the new pump station will be able to
operate at higher higher flood levels so
the old pump station effectively when it
floods the pumps get flooded were much
higher off the ground the Archimedes
screws can can pump more water out
they're fish friendly we we're compliant
with the national environment standards
for fish passage and really we'll have a
you know a real long life uh servicing
this community and other other rate
payers and and the airport for many
years to come and operationally
at much cheaper to maintain and and and
and manage than the old pump station so
it's quite a quite an important piece of
infrastructure going in there if you go
to the next slide to give you a sense of
scale that's a size there's two of these
uh screws going in that will uh that
will be fish friendly
and also uh make sure that the uh the
lake Hawkins area isn't inundated so
they they will continue to work and pump
pump flood water or drainage water more
accurately
if we go to the next
um slide
if you go down just once
if that's okay uh an important part of
our kind of BAU work
is our flood defense maintenance and we
do a range of activities around the
stock Banks to make sure that we uh that
we keep them in as best a condition as
we can spray and grass mowing one of the
probably the most um
uh
contemporary pieces of work that we've
donated to tree removals and so
um the reason for that is that the
really stock banks are there to keep the
community safe from from floods they
they're not multifunctional it's we're
lucky that we recreationally we can we
can use them but trees uh fences in in
flood events can topple they can create
holes in the stock Banks uh The Roots
can rot away and create channels in the
stock banks that the water can pass
through and create piping and and
leakage issues and effectively if not
managed uh can create a stock bank
failure and they're there to protect um
communities so we've recently been
through the Whitehall pie and removed
some trees we are in other areas doing
the same thing in Gore and and Windham
and not something uh particularly
enjoyed taking trees down I know people
are
passionate about treason rightly so one
of the things that I've sort of made a
commitment to is for every tree that we
take out we're going to replace another
Tree in a more suitable location we've
got the Southland riparian planting
program that we we manage and operate
that we we will do that and really the
challenges for us as an organization is
making it trying to pass the messages
around that it's not just cutting trees
down for SEC for tree's sake
they actually can be uh quite risky in
the wrong place and so that that's the
reason
um looking ahead on the on the last
slide I'm
trying to wrap this up as quickly as I
can because you may have some questions
we talk about a master plan approach I
alluded to it at the beginning where
we're constantly gonna need to strive
for more data and information to make
the right choices and I've and I suppose
the the the reach or the the statement
I've got for you today as an
organization is we want to continue to
work with you as an organization around
how we work in you in unison around our
footage management and
responsibilities and we would like to
come back to you in the future when
we've got some more of our hydrological
data or our bathymetric data that will
help us inform what decisions to make
around the next lot of investments in
invercargill and other areas so we see
you as a key partner in that
conversation and I'd like to come when
we've got the data to come back and
share that with you
um we are working together makes obvious
sense and you know your infrastructure
Works in unison with our infrastructure
so those things
need to continue and like you say it'll
be an opportunity should there be any
other funding available from the
government or potentially through our
respective ltps now and in the future
that we could work together on future
projects I'll leave it at that I think
we've covered quite a lot and I know
that you've got a busy schedule so happy
to take questions so I'll cover for you
before Tom puts his hand up
um
welcome Grant
the well-being of the Estuary the other
side of the stock bank is that something
you manage or we should manage or
collectively we should manage
I've got the question the the Estuary
the well-being of pedestrian
obviously you know that that is part of
the catchment and we
part of it will be asked an old historic
dump site that still causing issues
which Legacy issue which we're happy to
work with you guys to do something about
going forward with some of the
conversations have been around would
some strategic dredging
those decisions haven't been made but at
the end of the day we're going to have
to look at things through fresh eyes and
did a pretty good job after 84 but with
what we're seeing in the North Island at
the moment
um
then we might have had them in the past
but more likely to have them more
regularly so you've got we've got to
have plans we've got Land We own that's
um to be sacrificed to save invercargill
but will that be enough going forward I
know when
Napier they'd part of the shovel really
they built a 500 year return flood Bank
close to Napier it's still over topped
probably saved a lot of lives so that
you know this is basically what we're
dealing with today is actually
planning ahead for the next 20 or 30
years and really happy to work with you
if I may uh through you
um I know from a staff perspective we're
working we're sharing information on on
the Estuary and working together and uh
happy to continue that approach with ICC
so if there is a future projects or or
funding that's required that we can
approve happy happy to continue that
conversation I mean
it's no secret that there's Craig MP has
been numb working on trying to create
some boundary I guess around that
between the old historical Derby and the
and the yesterday where there's still a
lot of leaching I just wonder whether
it's an opportunity for us to collect
the leader hit down the government track
at some size to sort of say do we have
some funding that could help remediate
that my second question is more of a
political one so it's probably for
nickel more than more than anybody else
um just wonder what your view was um
when we look at the future of local
government
um I hear quite a bit of chatter behind
the scenes and the political parties
that would suggest while and the
automation is not on the not on the
agenda and the and the review may not go
anywhere other onto a shelf I guess
um
is there a future for the regional
authority to be not only environmental
but also climate change do you think is
that a natural fit
well the other is you know we're um
Lobby the mayoral Forum has us us to
lead the climate change
in advance but everybody working
together so that's that's that's not
going to change we're dealt with rivers
for years in some ways in the last
hundred years were straightened and put
up flood banks that we've actually we're
gonna have to think a bit harder about
that because we can't continue their
support stock bank's higher and higher
yeah so it's it's actually where where
can the water go which um when we get
the events that we know we will
eventually have but um yeah we we're
certainly up for that it's yeah but but
it is combined we've all got it's a bit
like I use the Emergency Management
setup we've got in Southland which is
probably the Envy of a lot of areas
um everybody's got skin on the game
we've got dedicated staff and I think
that's that's a good model going forward
yeah it's certainly been my reflection
is that councils tender
look for opportunities to be tick in a
few boxes on climate change but there's
nothing coordinated as a region winner I
would have thought the Regional Council
would be the ideal place to get some
uniformly of effort well we've just just
formed a committee which will have a
representative at a governance level as
well as staff so that is the plan we
need to have a regional approach with
otherwise you've got to have people
doubling up so you know right behind you
on that yeah thank you uh Tom no no I've
got you
we all know money's feiny and we're
never gonna have enough of it
um that
it really means that we have to do the
right projects
um and and that means the one that the
ones that data tells us are you know
where are critical vulnerabilities are
and I think there's a a risk and maybe a
Temptation you just go on and do stuff
you know well that's got to be the right
stuff
but my question is um whether there are
actually any very obvious targets that
we should be doing you know the plain
and obvious that don't require a whole
lot of data or reduce support but I said
first that we've really got to get the
data first yeah well that that's exactly
I think the I think the kanoa funding
came at a time would
perhaps across the country was 30 years
of not a lot of
investment in the infrastructure so
there was a desire to get on and do as
much as possible with that money you're
right we brought work forward
what what it's taught us is data is is
everything and the right data uh they
have you know I talk about hydrological
data and it's it's a term but actually
if you see hydrological data and the way
that it can uh inform the way you know
let's let's use the model to put stock
Banks up a certain level and let's put a
certain event through it and see what
how it performs and that certainly gets
you to a place where well hey that's the
infrastructure we need to invest in
because it's going to make the right the
right protection totally supportive of
you of those comments and that's really
what I want to do next time I come back
is to bring that data share it with you
and say well okay we're gonna look at
all the projects what what what does it
have to tell us I don't think there's
any
it's always challenging stuff this stuff
you know it stock Banks look simple but
they're actually well engineered and and
and and talented people make them happen
I don't think there's any real law
hanging through
um than the stuff that we've got on the
table but
um I'm hopeful for more funding
and I'm hopeful that that will result in
more more protection for invercargill as
we go forward but yeah
and I think what we've seen on the North
Island I think the government will put
more money on an ongoing basis into the
into this sort of climate resilience
space where there will give me money in
the next year or two I'm not not sure
you can see what's the devastation on
the North Island and some of it would
have happened anyway but lessons have to
be learned
day
pretty amazing you'll have a backup
generator for electricity in there yeah
I think some of this it's quite
phenomenal uh design so I spoke about
the fact that it's it's higher off the
ground it's it's less vulnerable than
the old pump station I think the
electricity components I think were
external are now within the building so
that offers a layer of protection as
well uh and yeah but I think the two
pumps themselves they back up themselves
and they also operationally cheaper to
run because uh they work off sensors now
and the amount of time is so actually
when they're not needed they're shut
down and it doesn't need demand power so
it's a pretty smart system that will
serve as well for 50 years just let you
see it now what the event has happened
up north you know some areas of develop
area for three weeks yes ridiculous yeah
it's a long time yeah when we found the
cost of having the environmentally
friendly pumps we did have a quite a
conversation with much more expensive
than we expected but its capacity is
much greater and I think with what we've
seen in recent months eye watering but I
think it's good investment
Grant yeah yeah just in terms of
modeling so
does environment itself on have the
models available to Overlay what
has happened up north in terms of the
rainfall event and then flow that
through air river systems to see what
where the water would go are we at that
point not not quite we've got lidar
information that's come in and anything
most of the regions waiting for some of
the lidar stuff to come through so
that's not too far away and an
overlaying that with the hydrological
models that we'll build that's the piece
of work that you're referring to that
we're we're taking the on the slide the
master plan approach which is bring all
of those components together and a lot
of the catchments merge into one here
and I think there's three major
catchments and they all work very
differently and so and so it'd be really
interesting when we've got that and
hopefully not you know maybe six months
to a year away hopefully
um we can start to bring that modeling
data back and you can start to see I had
the benefit of seeing westport's version
of it and it was very enlightening
really good information yeah and
supplementary sorry um so
are there other Regional councils
looking to pull resources around the
building of those models were they just
building them independently
I I know that we're different for
different river systems but there'll be
some fundamental infrastructure behind
those models that surely they're sharing
across New Zealand as opposed to every
Council spending the money themselves I
think we are and especially across the
south island and not just on the spot on
a whole other range of issues we're
actually working together
yeah we can't afford to have every
scientist in each building
you might have a specialist in the
consent area so so we're doing what we
can to actually lever a job without the
larger group and of course the regional
sector did put a paper together that did
probably
um that battle Jackson who was taranaki
at the time pointing out to government
but the amount of infrastructure that
flood the flood bank system actually
protected so that where that work is on
ongoing you get down to a specific thing
but you we've actually had some
expertise that have been worked in um in
in Hawke's Bay and other places down
here giving us that advice
um so where we can we're trying to do
that yeah but even on the modeling most
of our rivers are a bit slower moving
and
that their their guys had a pretty right
for 2020 on matara so so we get more
warning that um you sort of have have a
plan in place
the other reasons oh sorry
um
just a question about the experience
that
the tidality had with Timber slash
have we done any investigatory work on
what might be the risk factors for our
infrastructure if the worst happens and
it's a heavy rain event on
um areas that have been deforested
within southing because I you know as
you travel sometimes you see that
there's been some quite significant
deforestation has taken place how much
risk have we got
I think we're in a slightly better
position we've had a voluntary agreement
with most of the larger forests people
for quite some time and you don't but
I've been saying to ministers for some
time when they talk about intensive
wounded raising
buffering is important it's important
for forestry as well and obviously that
conversations going on in the North
Island at the moment and I
it's an event I've never seen before but
had they left you know at the bottom of
the hill and that was that you would
have solved around this stuff and you
know I think we'll get more coming out
of it the other thing is what do you do
with yourself after phone towers go down
um we've probably got to look at some of
the more basic stuff that everybody's
been throwing out so there's always
lessons we've had one or two people up
there we've got to share the learnings
should support but the learnings bring
back down as well
Mary yeah is it when we hit our last big
flood
um Kennington was a big big one out
there with all of the timber that's out
there now it blocked up the bridge
and then I think
they had to
take the pressure off and
take out one of this
um stop Banks
um have you talked to them out there the
timber place
specifically I'm certainly happy to go
away and ask that question I know that
um part of our annual inspections uh
maintenance program where we what what
the stock bank is and look at risks
that I did joining landowners are part
of that risk assessment but I'm
certainly happy to go away and ask if
we've had specific conversations with
with with specifics or you know activity
around specific activities
yeah
thank you for your delivery today I've
got a question really
um so I'm trying to get my head around
some of the technical data that you've
just given us and the hydrological data
and my understanding correctly that once
you click that data and it's working and
doing everything you want it to do then
the ability is it will give us a
predictive
collection of information that may
give us future advice of where we do and
don't build in terms of water flow
because I see from a lot of the
event in the north island is the
severity of the amount of volume that
was dumped in that width review in the
Cyclone story along with other natural
um or man-made issues going on
with it if you had the right information
for that productive
data
and we found that we had to do some
considerable work to improve our
infrastructure here
you would then apply to government
or infrastructure upgrades that would
include information from the regional
group here
well you you absolutely correct your own
why that doubt is important and what
would you be used for yeah
um we we've you know the the currently
we're finalizing our government-funded
projects we're near in the end
um hopeful
there potentially could be more
government funding but I think the data
that we need needs to be on the Shelf
ready to go at any given time where the
funding is available so
um if funding available and we've got
that data and it tells us that if we
build certain infrastructure in certain
ways it'll work
um but but I can't talk about
whether that funding will materialize or
not I'm not sure certainly we we have
the opportunity through our own
long-term plan processes
what load I will do was actually give us
real confidence on
areas where we shouldn't be boarding on
in the future where you could actually
divert water there's a lot of talk about
uh managed retreat but the first part of
managed Retreat is actually going to be
quite firm on where we should not be
building in the future because the
mandatory treat argument is hugely
expensive government will probably they
haven't even set up a fund yet right but
the first thing is so to be all on the
same page because we know that
developers will come along and take you
to the court and say no no we can do
this so there's some of this uh this
data is going to be very powerful and
actually saying actually no with this is
what we know okay so if I made a
supplementary to your answers
given
um
we are currently facing legislation
um under the three Waters reform
how do you foresee this productive data
placing Southland in an importance of
um funding mechanisms
I guess that's a political question
I guess I'm pleased that most both the
major parties are not moving away from
actually dealing with the issue I mean
it's a bit like the flood Banks there's
been no Government funding has gone into
infrastructure for the last 30 years and
we've now got a huge Legacy whatever the
answer is and we can argue
about about a centralized model but at
the end of the day there's got to be
funding available
and and there may be some it ever
changes that could be smaller smaller
structures because some small councils
it would be almost impossible to do so
we've actually got to have a mature
debate about and I'd like to see
a bit of um cross-party agreement at
some stage going forward because we do
we do need to deal with those issues and
otherwise we're going to have ongoing
issues and I talk about five orders if
we don't deal with storm water and
wastewater we're not going to solve
their problems and our estuaries and our
Rivers okay
yeah Alex I think give me a clock I've
just got kind of one
one question of is really just for
clarification in my own mind about how
um managed to retreat may be managed
with um
currently like if it was put through the
whole system and like you said the
developers want to develop in a specific
area in the district plan currently
allows for it but the hydro data appears
that that's going to be really low-lying
land that gets flooded or we manage
flood waters in that area it will get
flooded out what is it that will be the
mechanism that prevents that is that
going to be wrapped into the new RMA
changes and it be at a RMA Regional
level where that development will be
whether or not you can develop they will
be controlled or will that still sit
with councils under the district
planning sort of framework we don't know
exactly where it's going to land but you
know your spatial plans yeah all these
things are going to point us in that in
that direction I guess because as you
know yourself you might get somebody
saying well we don't really want you to
build there but if they've got the land
they're pretty determined to do it and
we saw it a bit I'm pretty strong on
local decisions that we need we need the
right regulation behind us to be able to
that enforce loads of sessions because
further down the track they'll say why
did you why'd you look yeah basically so
at the moment we'll have that data but
nothing to actually
just a little I'm not sure what we've
got in the existing area you know I
probably need to go away and come back
and answer that more more
comprehensively for you I I suppose from
from it
the the there's obviously going to be
wider benefits to the data and I suppose
that's the conversation and we need to
come back and share with you you know
that's when we have it I I expect it'll
be quite quite a uh Illuminating
experience will be quite rich and shows
lots of different scenarios and and uh
yeah it can be used for multiple
purposes and I think that's why
um on the slide it says we need to
continue to work together and use it
yeah
cute and more questions just don't wrap
up for you two guys
um some interesting debate
um currently over Urban Development and
the uh I guess the uh the need to build
up with not outwards in some cities
it was really interesting a couple of
debates the last couple days on
on TV early in the morning um about the
need to if you go up 10 stories instead
of going up 10 seconds you leave the
land around it with an ability to absorb
water you start coming with tarmac
driveway streets and everything else you
just you're creating a bottleneck
somewhere down the line so well we've
we've had this future and it's not just
the city it'll be Pockets out in the
rural areas as well that have
traditionally spread out that they may
need to think about some but he left
upwards as well so yeah
interesting future if you do guys and
thanks very much for your presentation
thanks for the opportunity and thanks
for your leadership yeah
public forum but it's it's good to have
this guy yes thank you thank you Paul
all right
we have to
get time
so now I guess they're gone just to uh
it was around missing me before not to
welcome the two new Michaels that are
sitting beside me so I Rose between two
Michaels as it were
um so everybody likes everybody likes uh
code so M1 over here and M2 over here
obviously the YouTube executive at his
first meeting and Michael's coming in
from a Governor's perspective as well to
give his advice that clear used to help
with so that I don't hear us down the
wrong path or something so if you just
want to work our way through the uh
through the agenda we've got a whole
series of minutes that we'll just skip
our way through and please yell out if
you need to have any discussion about
something
and we do have one late item
we just need a approval for so it's uh
the long-term plan our city or the heart
city center land Holdings so that's in
relation to Ico and I and the paper
brought up by Andrew so I could Service
uh Leslie not Darren you're excellent
yeah yeah just in case you couldn't see
what you were put your hand up for
um so that all those in favor I carried
so just working through these minutes
the first first set of minutes is the
minutes of the Southland Regional
Heritage committee meeting and this goes
back to the 23rd of September
yeah thank you
second them pro forma yeah thank you uh
any discussion on the minutes that are
in front of you
yeah being none all those in favor Etc I
carried
so you come on as the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting the community
wellbeing committee which is yours
Darren um yeah thank you
thank you
minister of the council meeting held on
the 31st of January move that way thank
you Leslie and bearing any discussion on
those yes great
Fox base 32 this reference their move
and Council sober and second and counts
on the ground
around the thing unless it's me so I
think it might be you yeah we can have
that in a minute
when we get there any other discussion
me being none all those a favor I
carried
and that's the infrastructure committee
meeting held on the Tuesday the 7th of
February right yeah I'll move that they
be received yeah second with my Pioneer
in your discussion
oh sorry my mistake party yeah I got you
seeking the police Grant I've got you
I'll counselor Grant
um all those in favor
Gary
well it's a bluff community board
meeting on the third Monday the 13th of
February happy to move those
yes thank you Leslie
yeah Darren always a good backup
in the discussion of those
there being none all those in favor
that's a community well-being committee
on the 14th of February
thank you Darren trash as well thank you
any discussion
none uh what is a favor carried
and it's the extraordinary meeting of
the infrastructure committee on Tuesday
the 14th of February I'll move that
they've been received thank you
yeah thank you Alex any discussion on
those
hey we'll do some favorite
Gary
another extraordinary council meeting on
Monday the 20th of February
I know yeah about anything interesting
day yes ring it thank you any discussion
there being none all those in favor
aye Jared
and it's of the finance and projects
Committee hearing
on the Tuesday the 21st of February
Grant thank you secondary checking that
Leslie any discussion
me being none
now moving on to some cool business so
the first paper up
that's Rivals oh there's a Trudy what do
you think it's you excellent all done
Trudy
um so it's a paper on the attendance
researcher for elected
and appointed members
they did
all the results from November through to
January this year
the floor was yours Michael or M2 thank
you Mia Clark it's a bit longer a
journey from up there down yeah yeah
um
oh yeah so this is uh the first time
that we have presented something like
this to council it is in response to a
regular leguma request most councils get
from our friends in the media and I
believe but I don't speak for them that
it's they see it as a way of holding um
elected members and appointed members uh
to account to make sure that you are
actually attending your meetings
um I don't make any comment on that
that's not my role but that is what I
understand the media use it for the
purpose of this is that each quarter we
will present a summary of the quarter
and then it will go up onto our website
um being proactively released to the
media and so with that I am happy to
answer any questions all right so before
you jump in part here
[Music]
generated cancellation and use whatnot
attended and the other thing is
um just another thing you've got DNA
against me or is it through the
discussion on Ira reform submission
it's not in my diary which I can show
you
so so Michael just a couple things for
me on the second page it talks about uh
when an elected member is absent but I
just want to clarify Epson does not mean
uh Zoom
babes it means well I'll be sure about
this zoom in it's still there
um the other I guess issue for me is the
whole nature of the report I know we
have to provide reports but it just it
feels a little bit uneasy for me I'll
let other people discuss this because
I've had some discussion about it with
some other colleagues as well this is a
little bit of a microscope over
attendance and one thing about
um when we first started off this
Council what seemed like a million years
ago
um we talked at length about
um it's about the quality work that you
put into Council as elect member not how
often you attend meetings I can show you
people at the team meetings that don't
put in a lot in the past and others that
don't attend so much but do a lot of
quality work so um I guess there's some
degree of unease around what happens for
the people amongst their group that have
full-time jobs and I know um two years
ago when we had the ltp workshops they
were very intense and I can't remember
but it was a couple of dozen maybe even
up around 30 of them and if you were in
a full-time job or even close that it
was just it was just near impossible to
get into those workshops so I do balance
that out against the need for staff to
get a feel from us in these workshops
and then not come back at a later stage
and have a whole lot of counsel saying
well actually don't agree with that I
know I wasn't there but I want to change
Tech now because that just doubles up
the workload and we can't afford that so
there is definitely a balance between
the two
um
but I just think it's a little bit
prescriptive and I know we have to keep
data but I'm not sure whether this is
the way to do it but I'm open for other
people to have some input into it
Alex oh thank you um
have any problem with it being recorded
but I would like it recorded factually
um there's two incorrect
um ones for me here as well looking back
at my records one is the 31st of the
first
um
extraordinary Community well-being
meeting which was before the council
meeting that very same day which I'm
recorded as an attendee you know the
chair can also confirm that I was
definitely there and the 8th of the 11th
which was extraordinary Council and then
infrastructure on the same day I'm
recorded as it just says mem which
um should be in attendance as well
um I think um Mia Clarke makes some
really uh good points as well
um there are some of us here that have
families and full-time jobs and I think
it's really important when it comes to
democracy because a lot of us you know
like you have one foot in the real world
as much as much as you have one foot in
the political world and maintaining that
diversity and balance of um
people right across the board is really
important for a reflection of our
community so removing all of the
barriers to entry and ensuring that we
do have a really long lead up to when
these meetings are scheduled is really
important so I'm looking forward to
working with the mayor on making sure
that happens in the future
thank you it's Michael just for your
benefit
um
when we started this term we very much
had a different approach to committees
so we haven't got most people on most
committees type stuff we've allowed
people to select where they feel
comfortable if you don't have a finance
background then probably being on the
finance committee is not the best place
to be some would argue you should be
there to learn but I mean at the same
for risk and Assurance which is a quite
a specialized area and you don't want
people just attending because they feel
as though they have to take all makeup
numbers so I guess I just want to make
sure that we've got the mechanism right
here that people who don't need to be at
some areas so for Home's sake if
somebody wasn't on a risk and Assurance
committee or wasn't on the finance
committee and we had a workshop about
that going forward you wouldn't expect
them to really attend I wouldn't have
thought given that the outcomes of the
workshop will go to those committees
where they're not attending so I just
want to know there's some flexibility
there without people saying well silento
did 95 last term the other person I did
85 that means a lot of people goes on
away from these workshops as well my
programs like what Nigel's day
absolutely
um Mia Clarke I agree entirely this is
about one measure of public
accountability sure uh one of the
advantages of having it presented to
council is that you will get to see it
whereas otherwise a leguma would Chris
would come through and it wouldn't
actually be something that you would see
until it's reported yeah
um yeah which is the advantage I
absolutely take your point there are
other
um we can
modify how we capture these to reflect
that not everybody as you say is on each
committee to ensure that that is perhaps
clearer because I think at the moment it
just shows in a
um saying that they're not on that
committee so it's it's a bit of a blunt
tool sure that's what we've got at the
moment but yes absolutely we will be
able to refine this as we
um gather more data no thank you
any other questions
yeah
um I sort of agree with me Clark
um these things obviously need
Ed to give the answer but
I just sort of have a couple of it we
issued with it because um
like to me it's just uh
a record of whether you're here or not
and to be honest I agree that it's more
about
the input of your decision making as
opposed to your attendance and I just
see this I know it sounds weird but
we've got school school boyish now if
you were professional people to run for
Council you know I don't believe that a
lot of them would like to be
put under a microscope so much I said
now there are rules as we know that if
you don't attend four meetings you know
you you're deemed to be to be absent I
don't think there's any need to have it
publicly displays it's got to be there
because you are if you are us you should
give it and as you should but the thing
is every three years we are held
accountable for our decision making and
what we do and whether we attend or
don't attend and of course as you know
those things do come up during elections
that the Brits will ask and it gets
published so be it but I don't think
it's something that we should actually
put out on a regular basis just to show
who's here who's not here who goes to
workshops and this is say there's no
requirement to go to workshops legally
speaking and a lot of us do have
families do have other businesses and if
you want our sort of people to wrap a
council you know they don't want to be
put under a microscope like this that I
attended or didn't attend I mean I run
for Council because my intention is to
intend and give
contribute to good decision by him
that's why I'm here otherwise I wouldn't
be here
and I think that a lot of people here
are like that these days not here
because 100 here for income I wouldn't
believe I don't believe we're here to do
a job
so I don't think you need something like
this to me this is even kind of childish
in some respects
just my view yeah I'll come later too
and and I guess just a caveat to that
Michael I do understand that you've got
to keep records
ask us anyway and the flip side of the
debate that Alex and I and Alan have had
of course is that
um if we really have a look at this
report and we've had people here today
so actually I was still at the meeting
there you've got it wrong you can
remember a year later it's way too late
you'll never remember and then when you
go to release something you're going to
have 13 people scrabbling all over the
top you're saying that you've got it
wrong so I understand where you're
coming from too yeah Leslie
thinks Mr mere you've made one of the
points I was going to make which is
sorry about that it's Barbie so to look
at the city at an attendance register
a fairly contemporary to the attendance
um if there are going to be Corrections
um
and just slightly contrary to
um what councilor Arnold said I think it
is a necessary part of a council that an
attendance register is kept
um
and I actually think it's a good idea
that we don't hear about it two or three
years after the event but are going to
see it on a regular basis which means
those Corrections have been made I mean
let's deal with requests under lagoima
as practically as possible by having the
information to hand rather than getting
the request and then scrambling about to
provide the information and I also
acknowledge the requirement
understanding orders that we have the
record kit it just seems to me it's
sensible and sensible that we're seeing
it
from now on on a regular enough basis to
be able to correct it in plenty of time
for it to be the actual record I also
point out that the legend
that is actually with the attendance
register does make it quite clear that
there's some categories where people
aren't members of the committee
and have or have not attended the
committee for interest sake and I think
there might be a couple of other
categories that could be added to the
legion but
um I did think that the the legion
categories were probably as descriptive
as you can make them
one of the issues that has come up is
that if I'm not on a committee say I'm
not on the risk and Assurance committee
and you run a workshop like we've here
today around risk why would I come to
the workshop if I'm I've got no interest
in the committee
um
I mean there is always the educational
side of like accept that but again we've
got to balance out the need for
um not just to have the council full of
people that can do this as a bit of a
full-time job
absolutely amazing acknowledge so
perhaps as a Way Forward
um continue to present these reports on
a quarterly basis but don't publish them
on our
website yeah just keep them as part of
the agenda that'd be helpful I'm
syndicating that is the sense of more
Comfort around the table
and we will work what we're going to do
with the workshops and bring that to you
at the next quarter yeah to show how
we're going to report that that'll be
helpful yeah hey on top uh yes
Mr me I wanted to acknowledge that I
personally think it's important there's
been quite a lot of challenges made
about the representation of monofinoa
the fact that people can see that we
come to all the meetings that we are
supposed to we also come to the meetings
like this one where we have no vote
but we are still both here it's
important both for the people for whom
we are the representatives and the
spokespeople but also for the public to
see that it's not just lip service we
actually do attend we do participate so
I actually appreciate this record I
asked for it when I was doing my
accountability back to
my group of um and it wasn't available
to me in this format and I appreciate it
very much and I thank you for the effort
that has taken to collate all this
information
the apologies of somebody else has
suggested us but
um I mean it seems to me that once it
appears in the agenda it's become a
matter of public record
for that reason it's important to berate
I think before the Earth appears and I
wonder where there's an opportunity for
um Michael's team to perhaps circulate
it a couple of weeks in advance so that
people can actually look at it and you
know challenge or say hey look you've
missed something so that the detainment
does appear on the agenda uh it's
correct yeah
check that on board yeah thank you
you feel that discussion tomorrow thank
you I'll second that thank you Leslie
um all those in favor of the
recommendations and there are three of
them
Gary
all right
next paper uh M2 again
a continuation on
um if you are aware from the very
inaugural meeting I indicated that your
delegations register the Council on
finance one is a living document and
we'll be subject to amendments from time
to time uh this is the second set of
amendments to it
uh we uh
simply
doing uh two changes we're adding in the
new role of Chief Financial Officer um
Patricia's role to ensure that she has
Financial delegations in the ability to
sign matters off
uh and there will be also updates coming
to the chief executive delegations
um just to tidy that up
um
and we've also added in a non-financial
performance indicators to the
um Finance
and our projects committee because that
only had financial performance
indicators and it was appropriate that
it had its non-financial indicators that
were within its scope of our business to
be included in there
and then there's so that the two key
changes to the delegations we just did
that are up today and then the last one
is just an update on Bluff delegations
uh towards the end of last trainium the
bluff leaderboard indicated that they
were unhappy with their level of
delegations and we undertook to do some
work with them so that they could
see what that could look like
um that project is underway and we hope
to be having a workshop with them in
April noting of course that any change
to the delegations must come through
this Council
but it was an opportunity for Bluff to
explore what they currently have and to
understand what they would like to be
able to do so that it can be brought to
this Council for consideration
understanding what the community board
would like to achieve
and Bluff so it's it's simply a note at
this stage that work is underway because
the last thing we of course wanted was
the council to be surprised by
a request for uh changes to the bluff
delegations
just one piece of feedback that I've
already spoken with uh Michael is the uh
the introduction on page 70 where it
lumps together manafinoa analytics
members so they are two different
designations it would be my preference
of below a link for me if you have
another title before you get the chief
executive that might say something like
minor thing or pointed represent us and
their role is advisory to both committee
and the full Council I think that would
be the clever like that smudges that
they have
and I don't want to belittle their rolls
but they don't have uh responsibility
for decision making
and that's um that could happen that
would be great I think that will um
absolutely be done there will be a
further delegations Amendment coming
through to the match uh council meeting
and something else has come up that was
too late to incorporate and this change
but that will be an opportunity for us
to make that change as well cool
yeah
already
thank you Mr Mayor Michael just uh some
clarity around
um I'll start with uh part A the
introduction and highlighted in Black
elected members to Executives and
Council officers under chief executive
it says
um Dash who is the sole employee of the
elected members okay so it states that
then we go across to
um the key council's principal
responsibilities uh that's paragraph 2.3
and it says that a local Authority
should be a good employer now can you
clarify if that means that council is a
good employer
to Michael
or is it a broader sense because I'm
just following on from that and it was
my understanding that that us 13 elected
members I have one employee yes so it is
one of those uh tricky parts of the
local government 2002 and that the chief
executive is council's sole employee
however Council also has obligations to
all the employees at the chief executive
employees to be a good employer it is
it's in the Local Government Act
um
I can help you Michael yeah um for those
who are around here last term uh when we
head
a debate about where the chief executive
of the time could reduce the wages down
by 25 or 50 during covert and the advice
we got from Ricky Donnelly was that
while the Chief Executive Signs and
employment contact with each employee
the tiling of their contract says
specifically on behalf of the city
council as the corporate body so we do
have some obligations to uh things like
well-being and what have you that it
doesn't leave us the moment we employ
Michael
yeah we have a knob location not to
necessarily provide that well-being but
to ensure that it is provided right
that's the advice we got from Ricky yeah
yeah no it's just following him on
previous discussion sure
thank you
any other questions
excellent
so we have that paper with that
four recommendations
you know with us again thank you Darren
and thank you Leslie
I can't do so yeah all those in favor
all right carried
the next paper is our city with a heart
Rhianna
curakoto
um so this paper is a opportunity for
Council to consider the elements that it
wants to confirm for the long-term plan
as we work to that next plan that will
start first of July 2024
so it's really a procedural report it
enables the officers to continue work on
all the elements as we work together
towards that plan and the City Center
Workshop that was held last week was the
first one that we have live streamed to
the public so the public will have seen
or had the opportunity to see many of
those conversations in this paper
summarizes and then brings those points
for council's consideration happy to
take any questions yeah
um just a reflection For You Rihanna
um I get good feedback from the
community about us live streaming
workshops wherever possible
people are getting to hear about it and
see a lot more transparency and
understanding of our thinking as we lead
into things
um the report for me is a really good
one
um it touches on some contentious issue
which is great because that's what we
need to go to certainly the issue of
improving non-heritage buildings which
you've got on there is a paper coming
forward
um and uh I think when we talk about
events see the event on Saturday down in
industry was great
this is going to be pretty darn an hour
later it was just there were people
everywhere so that's an opportunity for
us going forward to have more of those
type of weekends events in the streets
that really encourage that in the city
heart
and I was pleased that you also signaled
the issue about the corner of Kelvin and
Tay which I see we've got late
a late item for that as well so
yeah they're well presented
bringing oh sorry there
it's all right
thanks um
it's a it's a pretty accurate reflection
of what we went through last week having
shared that Workshop I was really
pleased with the level of Engagement and
the manner in which the discussion took
place and as we pointed out at the time
it was just the starting point of a
conversation that gives staff a
direction to go off
which we're formalizing today to come
back with papers which we then consult
and discuss in public so uh as a as a
procedure I'm happy to move the
recommendations
yeah Leslie and I'm happy to Second them
as a block because I actually think it's
a very good summary of where we got to
end the expectation that we had for some
meaty papers to pre-presented which
would carry us further forward so I'm
very happy to Second them to all nine of
them yep and so oh sorry right
thanks Ryan I think it's a pretty good
reflection of our discussion just one
sort of point
with on page 104 just around what a
place the options that are going to come
back are going to be for
um
walk in a place or a successful public
place
um
a street and development site
in the CBD so what I'm what I'm asking
is are we just looking at okay what do
we do with walking a place are we saying
where can we hear the uh public place
and a city you know that fits into our
city with heart in other areas around
the CBD
so the report in April will deal
specifically with option
um for walking a place but this paper
and asks the team to consider council's
priority that it's wanting to have a
meeting place so it will suggest and
consider alternatives
um but it is specifically focused on
what kind of place
but it what sorry if I can be clear it
will explain the implications and
provide some Alternatives
um but it may be that those Alternatives
there may need to be further scoped
sorry second request question yeah
I think it's really important that we
see
um
you know how we can achieve
some of the things that the paper
outlines you know so are Gathering Place
and a place where people can play and
those sorts of things but we look at
that with a pretty clear lens we don't
just get
funneled into or we're just going to
make walk into place beat this place if
that makes sense
so
um I think you know we need to see what
different areas around the city
potentially could be developed up into
what we're trying to achieve
um for a city with her
should I really let you talk
yes
um look in response to that question
counselor we will be as part of our
Urban playwork reviewing the broader
location and how we might see play
dispersed throughout the CBD so uh we
will be looking at other places aside
from Wagner place and in terms of how we
deliver that vibrancy
um yeah obviously I see this as the
first step and that's really no more
than the first step because uh the
options for Gathering space as
discovered in the weekend
um
if s Street was managed whenever it
suited best
to be closed off it provides a brilliant
Gathering space
nothing comes close to it the vibrancy
and accessibility so all those things
but they have to be done in conjunction
with approval of the retailers and
things like that so I see this as the
first step and then all that information
is going to come
so we just need to sit back
uh just for your benefit Rihanna
um I've had quite a bit of feedback on
both sides there what my place the
discussion there are some people that
died on a dish before we even touched
the place
um you know it's been there for a long
time and the young people that we've
spoken to recently are quite clear they
want a place to hang out use new words
um you know a place where a weekend they
could have some pizzas it'd be covered
they can have a big screen
um they can have some stubbies if we
were relaxed their licensing balls or
whatever so there is a definitely there
from that younger group when they're
they're the future of air City
um yeah thank you now this is was a
really good exercise some of the
feedback I sort of got is
you know why don't we shift State
Highway and stay highway to go around
the CBD rather than destroy it
so that was a different option that they
thought was of benefit so that it flowed
right through
to love the place
um thank you Rhiannon um
for recording what happened at the
workshop so well
um
the one thing that
as I walked around the city afterwards I
thought about with the um potentially
reacting walking a place was how would
that work with esque Street being a
one-way Street on this side and
potentially not being a one-way Street
on the other side in terms of
if that was if that was an option to
open it back up to traffic and also
looking at how tight that area has now
become that would mean to me it would
seem to mean remodeling the
um
median strips that in the middle and I
and I thought that that was a bigger
exercise than what we were actually
thinking about or talking about but
I guess for a lot of people they've
become used to the safety aspect of how
no traffic coming at you from that
direction because it's quite a short
space
so that was just the feedback I got that
that they felt like
it was least safe with traffic going
through the way it used to be
um and particularly what would the
challenges be with s Street now being a
one-way Street
um
and potentially the other side babes
being two-way
so
there are lots of factors to consider um
that's okay
um I think I just wanted to add to the
picture
um just around the traffic potentially
and not in a place and it's only one of
the options being explored but I think
that what we've seen in esk street is
that and and we will see when we do
reopen it to to traffic is that um
having a space that has traffic and
pedestrian can look different um to
perhaps what we've traditionally
perceived as a traffickable space as
well so
um I think when we talk about having it
open to traffic it may not look the way
it used to
um when it was a traffickable space it
may look something more like Astic
Street looks now but those are the
options we'll explore sure and I'll come
down and just adding to that um
we've had a lot of uh I guess Community
feedback I guess online feedback that
why don't you just leave the S3 closed
and it'd be great you can wander through
no cars no vehicles in it and obviously
the retailers were not comfortable with
that so I shared that recently with
counselors
um but it was really interesting when we
closed it off last weekend and we opened
it all went down again
we passed the retailers and said how do
you feel about this and they were just
blown away by it all
so they have the ability to bring that
foot traffic angle was great
so yeah they're like you say here and I
think there's some new thinking to go
around some of this stuff
um ringing look just that it seems to be
overlooked but
um stands out quite strong to me are the
four pillars of knowledge
that stand there in D Street I'm just
wondering what the future of of those
those will be
um
Darren looks like no no no I just I just
want to say we're actually getting into
this discussion that will follow on from
the options yeah being presented in
these papers we just don't we don't see
them mentioned obviously uh as as
something that needs to be considered I
mean this is the type of thinking that
could they could just be overlooked
because it's too hard it's the elephant
in the room and I just don't want them
to be overlooked I'm sure Rihanna will
have that covered up
we did talk about that the workshop
um
of the issues
any further discussion yeah being none
I've got a move on a signal that's
saying two each time
um
for those nine recommendations all those
in favor
aye Gary
the last one we've got on here is the
adoption of the fees and charges for
2023 24.
oh sorry being mindful this is just a
discussion document isn't it
it's not set in place so we're not
looking for a
anything more than just some background
information here
thank you Matt so um
this is uh
the fees and charges scheduled for
consultation so just to be really clear
what we are asking today is that you
adopt this for consultation and we will
take it out to the community for their
feedback
um we will contact various groups that
it may be particularly affected by some
changes in the fees and charges which
you can see highlighted within the paper
um I'll just like to draw your attention
to the fact that we have made some minor
corrections to the fees and charges and
there is a more recent version that has
been uploaded into your agenda that is
just the words for consultation on the
front page we're missing and there's a
Corrections on page three around some of
the corporate fees that had just been
um copied across incorrectly and a
correction to the menacing dog fee which
was incorrectly calculated that states
on page six that it was 154 it should
have read 156 dollars friends
um but also if possible like a
additional
recommendation to be added just to
delegate to the Chief Financial Officer
to make any final Corrections of
non-significant matters ahead of
consultation just if we pick up any
further
um typos Etc
um the report does speak to the work
that council with the officers and
managers and support has been doing to
ensure that the amount of Revenue that
we collect from fees and charges is set
at an appropriate level both in relation
to the legal requirements and the policy
requirements from the revenue and
finance policy and from the fact that we
knew from last year's annual plan that
we are over a number of years need to
just make sure we are collecting the
appropriate revenue from fees and
charges because if we are not then that
increases the rates Revenue that needs
to be collected
um so I'm happy to take any questions
just just the one issue which I raced
with you before which was and hear the
series who's sitting at the bigger than
anything couple
um is that when we push up the fees for
our housing just need to know the back
story behind that and how that will
Abate into
um
accommodation supplements available from
work and income we get a snapshot of
that and I mean I don't want to sort of
unit by unit but if we just get some
feel for that I think last time we
didn't have that and of course it's a
great storm
um and most of the 30 we pushed up last
time it was actually picked up by
working income not by our clients and so
if we could get that again just to know
what the actual impact is that would be
great I think
um I lost my colleague Heather to come
to speak to your question yeah
I think she was feeling cold we should
get away from all this
so what's your take on that healer
come here um my understanding is that
the
um majority of their tenants are on a
benefit and as such uh that will
increase
at the first of April
potentially they will also increase the
level of compliance for the
accommodation supplement
and so therefore air increase will
probably have very little
change to the actual final circumstances
I think if we could get some
confirmation from Elliot
IC that would be helpful we won't know
that until ones put out their actual
benefits sorry I'm sorry that's yeah no
I just think last time we had it most of
our clients actually set were set within
the ceiling was available to them yes
and we've been working with them to make
sure that they're getting the right
assistance sure thank you
Tom
yes the point I was going to meet Kim
meet as the pretty much the same one
that you met it seems to me that well we
can
um look at these charges and and almost
nod them through the one that does
require I think some discussion and
debate is that the question of increase
in rental sure
um because I lost seven dollars or so
you know seven dollars to people who can
afford seven dollars and we pretty much
know that I don't know how much in the
increase in
um 11 season is going to take up but but
I but I you know I I I I I I think at
this point we do need to
um talk a little bit more about whether
it's appropriate to increase those
charges
um just to give you help from last term
um I think at Wednesdays we were pushing
up
the average about 30 bucks a week and it
was a human outcry you would expect
people sitting here with placards and
beneficiaries Union was in here backing
them up but what we found out was that
27 of the 30 was actually picked up by
the accommodation supplement which means
wins pay for it
um are they getting allows for that so
the real cost was only uh three or four
dollars a week which was quite and once
I knew that that was fine
the key is just not to go down to that
debate again if we can avoid
yeah right you're like following on from
there and I think if you see the
increase in the transfer station charges
reflect that user pays is that these
people and and this accommodation would
would never fill a ribbon it was a
recycling bin so those who do frequent
the transfer station a lot for various
reasons we'll be paying the appropriate
levels that they should be to offset
um thing so I think it's a good tact the
whole methodology behind the fees and
charges
so Rihanna just just I don't know what
ring you just said though but this
doesn't affect a person that goes down
and stuff some stuff through the slots
on the side of the building it's really
the commercial people isn't it that
recycle
now this is transfer station yeah but
there are commercial people are going to
the transfer station that pay a fee for
going there yeah
will affect
those people going to the transfer
station all the fees will affect
everybody going not commercial and
non-commercial and the increase in the
minimum fees will obviously affect those
who are taking smaller amounts of
rubbish but the managers are
recommending these changes having done
full assessments of the cost noting that
they still don't cover the cost of
providing the service and that they are
still lower than many other councils are
operating in the area so that hence
their recommendation for why they're
putting forward the amount that they are
for consultation yeah what I was trying
to allude to is I mean I go in and I
take my plastic containers in and I
throw them through the slot I don't pay
for that no no this is sorry this is the
rubbish dump
not the recycling this is where you
drive in yeah green waste on the left
and I'm with you yes apologies Mario
misunderstood your question no no that's
all right that's all good then yeah
trash
seems to me that when vulnerable people
are in a house and they they get a
chance to get a little bit of um
increase
then we take it off
um I don't know you know you know I know
it's got to be practical but I would
like us to have some further discussion
about it
yeah it's an interesting debate that we
had last time because
um one we're well below the marketplace
for these vulnerable people two I think
when we did last time we had no waiting
list
so nobody wanting it and we were
actually accommodating people that had I
guess a younger age break in some cases
that were on uh England's benefit as
opposed to
oh sorry Darren
uh thanks Mick like I guess it's
important to understand that the if the
increase is not just to the benefit but
also to the accommodation supplement
yeah
yeah then that's only for accommodation
fine if that's all the increases that
we're taking
it could well be that of the seven
dollars or let's say an eight dollar
increase
the the client that's in the house or
unit may only pay two dollars
and the risk is gobbled up by the
accommodation supplement
unless they've got to the ceiling
and it's quite a generous ceiling I
suppose
yeah Alex it is worth noting too that
the reasons why um these Provisions are
made uh also so because we've done
significant
um upgrades to bring them up to Healthy
Home standards yeah whereas they were
previously not
so we're making improvements to their
home that they're renting off us so and
we need to be able to fund that in some
manner
well Rihanna might be able to help you
with some of that I mean Alex is right
we did get some shovel reading money oh
no sorry some three Waters money that
went more than two million dollars has
gone into those homes with air
conditioning units but part of the
process last time was to keep ourselves
reasonably competitive on the rent that
doesn't mean we want to be higher than
anywhere else but we want to have some
ability through what we get for those
units to be able to build more units or
to turn them over otherwise they just
continue to disintegrate
so that was a bit of a challenge for us
last time and we had a 30 increase
um it may be worthwhile for the new
councilors to have the paper we received
on the
on the plane for us to invest in some
future housing and I I do understand
that we are
at the beginning at least of of the
process of building some new units
um but it may be useful for councilors
to see
for the new councilors to see that paper
which did very carefully way up yeah the
the need for us to have that as part of
our plan for not only maintaining the
current units but looking at expanding
our housing stock
and um that that may be helpful in this
discussion and I I just point out
um we are
still
well under the average rental for
properties of the size of our units and
invercargill
about five copies Rihanna if you can
raise that you know the document that
Lizzie's referred to
I think it would be a good background
Docker for the for the ones that I knew
little ones I can't remember
okay
okay yes Michael's oh M1 yes through
yourself my smear
the uh deleg the item four that you put
up um I would ask given we're in a
transition period just at the moment if
you can put in a tailgate to the Chief
Financial Officer and or
the acting GM Finance assurance
just because it might be right on
transition
okay and just yeah just one thing just
to be mindful and Rihanna's already
touched on this that we've got some
pretty hefty uh water rate increases for
some a number of people so you're going
to write out to them or give them a
little heads up here because there are
some significant increases here
for sure Alan I was just going to talk
about the water actually goes oh sorry
consumer of uh water is a water meter
um it says that you know you're the cost
of delivering a service is 1.57 we're
paying a dollar fifty four you're gonna
increase that the cost by 25 percent
instead of a you know like a
0.03 or something like that
um I'm just thinking if invercargill was
to go to a metered system
throughout which is being proposed in
the three Waters I think that's sort of
going to be one of the outcomes of it
this would be like a major Cash Cow
wouldn't it with that increase
I mean you know the imagine how much
you'd make then
so just to clarify this is the fee for
the
um large volume consumers that are
collecting water from the system rather
than the residential just to be clear
um so it does a primarily businesses and
organizations but not solely
um
and
yes we are
charging at the moment significantly
less than the actual cost of delivering
the service and under the new water
entity it is likely that rates for
commercial and large volume users would
increase significantly again where they
would put their cost of delivering the
service and therefore the price that
they are charging is not yet obviously
known at this time
um
at the moment we're recommending this
increase as a partial move towards a
closer parity to the actual cost of
delivering a service
so just as a flow on terrible pun that
that is from what Ellen raised um
the councils that do have water meters
and actually don't make money ever
what they do is they decrease the demand
because there's a user pay system so
people use this water because they've
got to pay more if they if they just
have 20 minute showers type scenario so
what they does is it the savings is
actually at the treatment end
when you put the water in and at the
discharging you have less to less to
treat as well so that's where the
savings care
but the new entities won't discuss water
meat at the moment because they are
already unpoppy with about half the
population
okie dokie oh Leslie
um just for the benefit of those
watching online
just wanted to clarify that
was actually to the New Zealand average
for me to Consumers the dollar 57 was
invercargill's cost to deliver the
service but air increase and fees is
from the current 76 cents to a dollar
per cubic meters
so I just didn't want people to have
heard the reference to 1.54 and 1.57 and
then be con been confused about the
actual increase that's been posed which
is still not at the level of a dollar
fifty four or a dollar fifty Seven yeah
thank you just just wanted to to clarify
that
um not not that that takes away from the
fact that there are some water consumers
who would quite rightly will be
informing because they are large volume
commercial consent customers but
I just didn't want any contribution to
have resulted from those watching online
yep thank you for that Tom
just reflecting on the housing
discussion again
um and you know picking up you know
Dan's point and I think Leslie's too
um I mean it's not clearing me whether
the accommodation supplement increase is
gonna consume all of that seven dollars
a million dollars of whether it's gonna
it's gonna consume part of it
um
I I mean I would I was just like to hear
before we approve that and I think it's
good to go to your consultation and then
it comes back to us doesn't it of course
I think when it comes back to us
um I would like to understand the
implications to individuals but it will
actually cost them as opposed to what
will cost central government where
I'm greatly concerned but um
I would like to understand what will
actually cost them before we approve it
next time so the price he says we are
going to go to consultation anyway uh
Rihanna and Heather will have that
information before we go because we all
get questions on as we did last time it
was we probably got the greatest
emotional feedback last time about this
issue it was it was quite uh quite
strong so we'll we'll have that
information in their back pocket before
we go to consult so when we get those
questions we can answer them
no unless he had a handle first
sorry I just wanted to clarify we'll be
able to give I guess some generic
um information about the impact but
obviously the difficulty is that
everybody's personal circumstances
impact how much they are able to get in
terms of supplements so
um it we can't I guess give you precise
details of how it impacts everybody but
we can give you I guess a feeling for
where a majority might sit
Lucy thanks Mia I was going to make a
similar Point um we can't we can't for
privacy reasons um go one by one through
our current tenants but it may be that
it would be useful to ask
um either work and income or Southern
beneficiary and Community rights who
submitted last time for some generic
examples that could be provided to
counselors
um
which I think would be helpful for
people to understand for instance
depending on the particular income and
so forth people may not at the moment be
eligible for the full
um
subsidy yeah the key I think is is not
is not the sub here it's a ceiling it
says for the ring yeah
fall below the ceiling you get you get
the accommodation if you what portion of
your rent goes above it you don't get it
so you don't get let's say
um or you're in paid for if it goes up
to a certain maximum level and that that
will move like you say here and probably
in April this year because they adjust
the benefits every year so we can just
get some generic figures I mean Ali gave
me some last time we had that debate and
it was really helpful it allowed the
people that we're dealing with to go
away and do their own assessments we'll
get some help from you to do that
okie dokie
three recommendations on the table
Darren
oh trash any further discussion
there being none okay what's your
favorite I carried
okay some of you like to move we're
going to PE
I'll move that way Leslie Darren thank
you very much always a favorite say hi
Carrie
thank you